So, five days have gone by, you've not heard anything.
Here's what to send.
So, start your email with the subject heading of:...
"Thank you following the interview on..." and then put the date.
So, "Thank you following the interview on..." and then put the date the interview took place.
And then put "Dear Sir" or "Dear Madam," whoever it was who was interviewing you.
"I would like to take this opportunity to thank you..."
"...for interviewing me for the position of... on the following date."
"I am genuinely excited about the prospect of working for your organization."
"If you need any further information, details or evidence to help you make a decision,..."
"...please do not hesitate to contact me."
"I look forward to hearing from you."
"Yours faithfully," and then sign off with your name...
...and don't forget to put your mobile telephone number at the end of the email...
...so they can contact you.
Now, that is a polite nudge or a reminder if you like to let them know...
...that you're still very much interested in this position...
...and it's sent in a professional manner.
And that's the most important thing to do: it's to send it after five days...
...if you've not heard anything...
...and make sure the email follow-up is professional.